Dietrich's in Oklahoma says Dave I know
you're 100% against financing however is
it okay to finance a 0% for example
purchasing furniture set from rooms to
go with a 0% interest rate Dietrich we
just finished a study of ten
thousand-plus millionaires not a single
one of them out of ten thousand said I
got rich by borrowing money to buy my
furniture at zero percent I tricked
rooms to go into making me wealthy
I bought a car at zero percent I bought
off whatever at 0% it's everywhere right
now let me ask you since no millionaires
say that and since we know that banks
charge interest on loans how is it that
you think these people are loaning this
money at 0% have you thought that
through is it possible that the pricing
at rooms to go or rooms there they went
or whatever the company that has 0% best
buy or whoever is it possible that the
pricing is built into the price of the
item the interest rate is built into the
price of the item that you're purchasing
do you think use your noodle Bubba
seriously and if not that they have
really good data like most of us in
business who study our data it says out
of a thousand people that take out these
0% loans the vast majority of them don't
pay it off during that time by the way
it's about 88% and so during the 90 days
or during the 1 year they don't pay it
off and if you don't pay it off you know
what happens it goes into a regular loan
and they back charge you through the
year or the 90 days or whatever the
period of time is for the interest I'm
one of the 12% that does pay it off ok
that's fine
but you understand that on average
you're paying for this
and so I don't understand why you want
to play with snakes if you want to play
with snakes you can play with snakes I
don't play with snakes because snakes
bite and some of them are kill you when
they bite you and the others just hurt
and so why play around with these people
they're gonna bite you and nobody gets
rich borrowing money and 0% interest
never met a single one not a single guy
said you know I bought all my TVs and my
furniture do you represent interest
that's how I got to be a millionaire not
one they all say I avoid that like the
plague because it destroys my most
powerful wealth building tool which is
my income